holy macaroni there's a lot of you now
there's like 40,000 there's more there's
more now I promise that I do a QA after
reaching 40,000 subscribers I didn't
think I get here quite so soon but here
we are so I asked you guys on my
Facebook and Twitter send me questions
and I'm going to rattle through these
now so this is just a quick video to say
thank you for thank you for being
interested in what I make it really
means a lot from at the North II did
YouTube help you financially through uni
if so how much the answer is no not
really
if you're a small-scale youtuber like me
you really don't earn much money at all
you don't do this for the money you do
it because you like doing it a really
common question I'm just gonna pick on
this one from Tom Benford who asks
what's my plan after doing my PhD I want
to do video production so I want to
specialize in making videos about
science and about higher education so
doing stuff on this channel but that's
going to be part of it it's also going
to be making videos for other people
like X to uni like other universities
I've already been asked to sort of give
talks and people have been interested in
in me making things for them so I don't
really wanna think about it too much
because after the PhD is a very scary
time to think about because it involves
having done the viber and having written
my thesis but yeah that's what I want to
do I want to do combined science and
media into into one and to do science
video making Jules sets I asked how can
I stay positive after an Oxford
projection and is it a good idea to try
it in for a master's it possibly means
that you dodged a bullet because if you
didn't do very well in the interview
that probably means they wouldn't have
learnt very well in the tutorial setup
which means you would've been better off
going to uni somewhere else not they
weren't good enough for Oxbridge it's
just that maybe your learning style
didn't quite match with the teaching
style there however there's no reason
why you shouldn't go for a masters
because the teaching style will be
different especially if it's not a tour
course jamol ask what prep work would I
advise people doing an undergrad who
want to get for a PhD to do I think the
best thing you can do is to make sure
your CV shows that you are passionate
about what you want to research so
ideally you'd want to be able to do a
research project like I did over the
summer of one of your undergrad years
ask academics directly email them just
saying have you got any work can I do a
summer project I'm really interested in
what you do
it might not be there's funding
available you might just have to take
that hit if you can but you've got to
get something on your CV that shows that
you're capable of doing independent
research and then your supervisor from
that project will give you an excellent
reference it worked for me anyway
Sally LePage has asked what do you like
most about citing the page Tom asked
have I fixed my code
tom is the other PhD who I work with you
know full well that I haven't yet Tom
Ellie asked what do you think you'll
miss most about being in school where by
which I assume you mean uni um I was
actually wandering around the campus the
other day and we had live music on and
that was like hey a market on in the
main university building I just never
think I'm really going to miss the
atmosphere I'm really gonna miss the
feeling of belonging to a huge community
and something where no two days are the
same you go into the university and you
could see basically anything it's so
vibrant it x2 in particular is so it's
got such a great campus I'm really gonna
miss that Katie asked if I'd ever
considered doing a meet and greet event
or a meeting geek event she suggested
first of all I do love the name um
basically I wouldn't I'm not opposed to
the idea it's just I don't really have a
big enough fan base and I don't really
like that word to justify doing it
anywhere just yet if you were to put you
all in one place you'd feel like a
stadium which is mental but you're all
scattered all over the globe which in
itself is very cool but it doesn't mean
that if I was to do a meet-up somewhere
that there's gonna be very few people
it's give me two people and dog and much
as I would love to do a meeting with a
dog I don't know maybe next time in
London we could try on that subject
actually Molly asks cats or dogs a
better feed dogs
I do love dogs I really really do love
dogs but I've always been a cat person
we grew up with a cat I think we I was
any child uh-huh I grew up with a cat
and Henry was like my best friend when I
was a kid I just I think I think in the
same way as a cat also prays from dogs
is meaningless like dogs will love you
if they've just met you
whereas if a cat genuinely likes you it
shows you affection you've earned it it
means a lot more someone whose Twitter
name is just the union flag has asked
what are your strongest what's your
strongest personal qualities
do I have any I have a certain Pig
headedness about me I I kind of refused
to accept defeat
like I don't stop until I accomplish
what I want to do or I've just like
passed out in the floor I don't give up
easily more often than not that's
because the problems impossible which I
found several times my PhD I have like
tried to make something work where it's
just it's just impossible but I'm too
pigheaded to admit that so it's kind of
like a positive thing and a negative
thing I guess Blair has asked to Japan's
have a name for you if you a girl yes I
would even called Abigail I think I
would have suited Abigail Louie has
asked what are you most proud of
um I had to think about this earlier
because I find it really difficult to
think of anything that I'm particularly
proud of
in all honesty like I've done things in
my life that I know I should be proud of
like I should be proud of the fact that
I went to Oxford and I got a degree
there whatever um I just don't feel an
overwhelming sense of pride about
anything I've done yet I think the
closest thing would be the YouTube
channel because that's the thing that's
made the most difference for most people
it's actually helped people get into
Oxbridge it's helped people talk about
mental health and get help when they've
needed it but even then I struggled to
be proud of the YouTube channel because
in my head I feel like I shouldn't be
proud of it I'm just terrible at
reflecting on myself in a positive way
basically at this point I'd like to
introduce the Kendra section
Kendra is has been a fan of the stuff
that I've made for years
as soon as I start to vlogging in Oxford
I'm immensely grateful because I do
recognize you people who have been in
the comment section and and supporting
me for years and I'm so so grateful
because without you guys I probably
wouldn't have kept doing what I'm doing
so thank you so much and Kendra thank
you in particular because you've been so
enthusiastic about helping me improve my
content and supporting me so thank you
so she's asked a whole bunch of
questions I'm gonna try rattle them off
as fast as I can what's your favorite
possession and why um um I just had to
think what do I own favorite possession
I'm not a very sentimental person so I
do have objects that mean something to
me but I think I'm just gonna go for my
computer because it's the most useful is
that really bad or possibly the camera
that I'm filming this on because it
allows me to tell stories and to make
things and that's what I love doing
probably the most which country would
you most like to visit and why I really
want to get a rural China there's
something called elation Buddha which is
the largest Institute statue in the
world I've always wanted to see that and
that go on a trip with my best friend
that will Iceland I think and then
lastly would you consider going vegan
and if not why not
um I would absolutely consider going
vegan I've considered doing it maybe for
a month for exactly the same reasons
that I'm vegetarian which is for
environmental reasons reducing my carbon
impact I would struggle because I do eat
a lot of dairy products like I don't
drink milk but I do eat cheese for
example but it's definitely something
I've you open to maybe it's something I
could experiment with in the future in
ace has asked what's your favorite type
of content your create um it depends I
really do like doing vlogs and sort of
letting you follow me around during the
day because it's a challenge it's a real
challenge to sort of make that
interesting taste like very interests
but I do also like doing science content
the big series that I'm working on at
the moment which I've been sort of
dropping hints about is a big big
science series and that's a whole
different challenge that's like a really
polished production the thing about
vlogs is that they're great they're
quick and they're like fast food videos
because you just smash them out as
quickly as you can
with science proper
content long-form content you have to
take your time and I like both in
different ways also what are you doing
for the holidays probably writing my
thesis Union Flag agendas ask is there
adequate support for ox with mental
health if you ask for it yes I think
there's still a lot more needs to be
done in terms of getting people talking
about mental health same as a lot of
universities possibly more Oxbridge
though because it's just such a
stressful environment Javon has asked
how do you stay focused and motivated to
study and work on your essay for long
periods and pulled an all-nighter yes I
pulled two all-nighters
in terms of how to stay focused and
motivated I think there's a difference
between motivation and discipline I am
not necessarily motivated to work a lot
at the time but I am disciplined to work
so I will get up I will get to work
early in the morning ideally you know
like a nine o'clock certainly undergrad
you just get up go to the library do the
hours you get the work done that's not
necessary because you want to do it's
because you know you need to do it
that's discipline almost done daniel has
asked what's the position of your PhD
colleagues a mentor toward your vlogs
who've been judged by others because of
it not negatively I don't think I think
people seem to think it's a bit funny
which it is it's a very weird thing to
talking to a camera and then have
thousands of people around the world see
it but everyone's been very supportive
when I've asked people to do interviews
for example for my series about cop21
which is over here we probably did watch
it because basically nobody did all
those academics were very very willing
to give up their time and very
supportive of what I do and I think when
people realize that it's what I really
enjoy doing there they're really
supportive which is great and then
lastly jack has asked how early during
your undergrad your masters or another
time did you know what your research
topic would be now at the start of my
PhD there was a broad research topic
given which was stratosphere troposphere
coupling I was then allowed to find my
way as to what I really wanted to answer
and I think it was probably around my
start my third year when I kind of
clicked but yeah that's the exact
question that I want to do there's a
saying kind of amongst PhDs that a PhD
is three years of training to do a PhD
in six months and that basically I think
has wrong true with me like there was a
lot of stuff that I did at the start
which wasn't isn't gonna end up being in
the thesis at all but it allowed you to
find your way and it's almost like
locking in an answer on a quiz show or
something it's like yeah
that's what I'm gonna do and then you
just just go for it right that's quite
enough um I just want to say thank you
this is it's just amazing that I'd ever
be in this position I remember starting
YouTube and being such a nobody I mean
to be fair I'm still a nobody on this
side let's not have any delusions about
grandeur here I'm having delusions about
adequacy but watching the first hundred
views clock in on a video when I started
to recently it being thousands of tens
of thousands of views on a video is just
I'm just incredibly grateful I really am
I'm grateful that you find what I make
interesting because there's so many
other things you could be doing probably
more productive things I know a lot of
you watch my videos procrastinate and
I'll tell you a secret that's absolutely
fine but you choose to watch me and that
might be because you like how I present
things might be like how I edit things
but you appreciate what I do and like
anybody in this situation all I can do
is say thank you very much I'm going to
keep trying to improve and keep trying
to make better content so thank you for
sticking around I hope you continue to
watch videos on this channel and that
you come with me and continue to join me
on this journey into the scary real
world when I graduate thank you for
watching I'll see you in the next video